hey what's up guys it's marquez from the
mkbhd channel and today we're going to
be taking a look at the most important
and the most impressive feature of the
samsung galaxy nexus and that is the
display the screen is a stunner it's
what you use every time you use a phone
this phone's rocking a 4.65 inch
1280x720 super amoled hd display now i
actually already did a video by itself
on why ammo led displays are amazing so
if you want to check that out that's the
annotation right there so basically in
everyday use the screen really spoils
you if you get used to the screen it's
hard to go back to something like a
tablet with a screen that's less sharp
or less vibrant or less responsive now
here's something cool to note about this
screen you've probably noticed i'm using
some dark apps and i'm using a black
background every time that an oled
display has to display something black
it just doesn't light up the pixels at
all so as you can see here this is my
little oled display test where you can't
even tell that the screen is on unless
there are colors on it if it's black it
looks like the display is off so
everything every time you see a black
notification bar or the black bottom of
the display everything that's black is
saving battery so this is definitely a
really cool feature and a handy tip if
you want to get a couple extra minutes
out of your phone battery now gaming is
a whole new world on the galaxy nexus
using the the 1280x720 display kind of
shrinks down things to look like they're
on a tablet because that's a tablet size
resolution so like angry birds here kind
of looks a little bit tiny you have to
zoom in to play well
but games that uh work with a high
resolution look absurdly good i mean
it's really sharp colors pop and it's a
breeze a joy to use but the killer here
the absolute jaw dropper is watching
media even watching a simple high
quality youtube video or a movie trailer
or just a good looking video on youtube
when it fills up to the full screen
which is what it does when you're
watching video it looks amazing it's
full 1280 by 720 very sharp very
accurate colors pop it's like having a
movie in the palm of your hand this is a
by by itself could be a reason to want
the galaxy nexus forget ice cream
sandwich this movie consuming experience
the media consumption is just jaw
dropping and i absolutely love it
having that huge amazing screen is also
perfect for typing uh the ice cream
sandwich keyboard is great and coming
from a phone with a physical keyboard
it's only been about a day and i've
already gotten used to it so clearly
they've done something right the screen
and the keyboard combo is really damn
nice also in landscape mode there is a
huge keyboard
so as you can see by my ramblings it's
pretty easy to type and correction is
good don't make a lot of mistakes
and it looks good i think it's really
good looking looks like i continue to
like my phone how i like women but
overall uh yeah this is the best screen
i have ever used and you can argue that
the htc resound or the iphone 4 and 4s
or some other phones might have better
quality displays and i say just
throw ammo led in there throw an oled
display in there with pitch black blacks
and uh you got yourself a hell of a
screen i gotta say i am
very very satisfied with the display
again if you'd like to see any other
parts of the galaxy nexus highlighted
before my full review which will likely
come after i've really thoroughly tested
the phone let me know uh but this is
just the whole screen experience so i
hope you enjoyed it and uh give me a
thumbs up if you feel awesome either way
this has been mkbhd thank you for
watching and i'll talk to you guys in
the next one peace
you